marca el primer mes desde que rusia
empezó su barbarie en ucrania su
invasión
tuvimos una cumbre en la otan al
siguiente día en ese momento nuestro
objetivo principal
era tener una unidad absoluta en tres
temas claves importantes entre nuestros
aliados y socios europeos el primero era
respaldar a ucrania
con asistencia humanitaria militar el
segundo
era imponer las sanciones más
significativas
en lo económico en contra de este
régimen para disminuir la fuerza de la
economía rusa y castigarle por sus
acciones en tercer lugar era fortificar
el flanco oeste de nuestros aliados de
la otan que estaban profundamente
preocupados
por lo que podría suceder
logramos nuestros tres objetivos y hoy
estamos determinados a sostener nuestros
esfuerzos ya construir a partir de ellos
eeuu se comprometió a brindar más de dos
mil millones de dólares en equipo
militar o gran ya desde que me volví
presidente sistemas antiaéreos sistemas
antitanque munición en nuestras armas
están llegando ucrania mientras estoy
hablando hoy anuncio que los eeuu están
preparados para comprometerse a brindar
más de mil millones dólares más en
asistencia humanitaria para ayudar a
darle alivio a millones de ucranianos
afectados por la guerra en su país
muchos refugiados ucranianos
quisieran quedarse en europa cerca a sus
hogares pero también daremos la
bienvenida a 100.000 ucranianos a los
eeuu con el enfoque de reunir familias
invertiremos
320 millones de dólares para
aumentar la resiliencia democrática y
defender los derechos humanos en los
países vecinos también estamos
coordinando con el g7 la unión europea
temas de seguridad alimentaria así como
seguridad energética
podremos hablar más de esto mañana
también anunciaremos nuevas sanciones
a más de 400 individuos y entidades
estén alineadas con la unión europea'
más de 300 miembros de la duma oligarcas
y compañías de defensa rusa que aumentan
y que alimentan la maquinaria de rusa de
guerra sumado a las fuerzas dulces que
están ahorita presentes para defender el
territorio de la otan la otan estableció
como ustedes ya saben cuatro nuevos
grupos de batalla en ucrania hungría
bulgaria eslovaquia para reforzar el
bloque este putin estaba apostando a que
la otan iba a estar dividida mi
discusión temprano con él en diciembre
enero me dejó clara que él creyó que no
podíamos estar cohesionados la otan
jamás jamás ha estado más unida pero que
hasta ahora
putin está obteniendo el resultado
puesto que pretendía como consecuencia
de ir o crank ya hemos construido esta
unidad con la unión europea y con las
democracias líderes en el g7